falls ihr gerade etwas essen sollte dann
hört am besten auf weil das video jetzt
wird ein bisschen ekelhaft ich hab ein
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
spannendes thema für heute meine lieben
freunde beziehungsweise ganz spannende
videos rausgesucht auf die wir heute
gemeinsam reagieren werden und zwar
essen das schlecht wird aber nicht nur
bis es dann ein bisschen schimmel hat
sondern richtig über zwei drei monate
time labs von daher würde ich sagen
fangen wir direkt an hier mit dem burger
time labs battle wir sehen hier auf der
linken seite einen frischen burger also
wirklich einen frisch gemachten bürger
mit einem fleisch was irgendwie von der
fleischtheke im supermarkt die cetera pp
und hier ist ein burger von mcdonald's
und man sieht schon man sieht man das
jetzt nicht so appetitlich das krasse
ist halt wirklich so wir sind jetzt bei
20 tagen seht ihr unten links
eingeblendet der linke burger ist
komplett voll mit schimmel so wenn du
den frisch bist du wahrscheinlich
instant auf dem friedhof und beim
rechten burger passiert absolut gar
nichts wir sehen dass der salat ein
bisschen austrocknet aber im vergleich
zu dem linken dass das das zeigt mir
halt irgendwie so wenn man nachts vom
feiern irgendwie noch bei mcdonald's
vorbeiläuft oder bei burger king und ich
meine ich hole mir da meistens halt
wirklich immer nur pommes weil ich weiß
die bürger liegen seit mehreren stunden
aber stellt euch mal vor ich krieg das
sonneberger und ihr seid ein bisschen
angetrunken wirklich wird da trotzdem
rein weil ich denke er ist frisch und
ich meine es geht ja noch weiter müssen
jetzt bei 35 36 37 tagen der linke
burgerfeld immer mehr zusammen so das
brötchen klar das ist so das was ich so
am längsten noch hält aber die anderen
sachen sind halt alle frisch mehr oder
weniger und die haben jetzt auch schon
hingeschrieben after four days haben die
das ganze gestoppt weil sie das material
haben was sie sich erhofft haben so und
dann haben sie jetzt nur noch wenn ich
das weiter auf play drücken nur noch den
rechten bürger laufen lassen
weitere 40 tage wir sind wir sind hier
bei bei 373 und ich meinen schafft es
der liegt hier fast doppelt so lang wie
der und er sieht noch fast frisch aus
da schaue das heute allerdings nicht und
bürgern sondern auch noch ein döner der
hier haben wir jetzt keinen richtigen
vergleich im sinne von hey das ist ein
frischer döner und das hier ist ein
döner den man irgendwie bei mcdonalds
oder keine ahnung was bekommt all das
gibt es halt augenscheinlich wirklich
einfach nicht nur der wird ja immer mehr
oder weniger frisch gemacht deswegen
sehen wir hier auch schon nach einem tag
sehen gehen doch schon die ersten
fliegen dran
man sieht das ganze klappt ein bisschen
mehr zusammen jetzt sind wir hier schon
bei zwei tagen angelangt und jetzt mit
72 stunden schon beim dritten tag ich
würde sagen ich bin mal ein bisschen
weiter vor und wie z
[Musik]
m
dann
denn würde ich jetzt nicht mehr essen ja
meine lieben freunde also ein schöner
würde ich dann erstmal frisch essen als
als nächstes haben wir ja eine time labs
von milch also von einem glas milch wie
simon umgekehrt damals schon schlau
gesagt hat milch es gibt mit der
einstellung gehen wir jetzt auch hier
rein ich selber muss sich allerdings
auch ganz ehrlich zugeben sieht das
ähnlich wie simon also ich denke mein
gott das sieht so aus wie wenn man wie
wenn man hätte das wenn ihr so eine
tablette oder so in so einem glas wasser
auflösen das so ähnlich wie das so ein
bisschen geradeaus
ja obwohl vielleicht auch nicht was ich
gerade noch sagen wollte war auf jeden
fall dass ich das ähnlich sehe wie simon
und ich selbst trinke seit sechs jahren
keine richtige milch mehr klar wenn es
im restaurant jetzt in der soße drin ist
oder keine ahnung was dann
selbstverständlich irgendwann der saale
drin ist oder so aber jetzt so richtige
milch trinke ich auch nie mehr weil es
einfach wirklich schaut euch brooks
darüber an das ist wirklich schlecht für
euren körper es ist jetzt nicht gift
aber es ist ja das is ja es sieht ein
bisschen aus wie sonnen cacau muss mal
kurz überlegen
hmm
m
normal gerechnet
nein ich finde es halt so heftig dass
man halt wirklich einfach was stehen
lassen kann und es sich so krass
verändert einfach ein nahrungsmittel so
wenn man vorher ein glas milch den hatte
passiert damit nichts aber nach ein paar
tagen so wie sie das so darf es nicht
ziemlich krass die natur und das hier
ist die nächste teil apps und zwar es
ist eines von einem glas wasser
wir sehen ja schon ein tag da ist noch
alles gleich zwei tage drei tage und
jetzt schon beim vierten tag angekommen
ich frag mich echt ob beim wasser da
überhaupt irgendwas passieren wird außer
vielleicht irgendwelche kalkablagerungen
oder so oder allgemein irgendwie also da
wird jetzt kein schimmel kommen aber wir
sehen auch wenn sie schon mal man genau
hinguckt da passiert irgendwas jetzt um
sogar an ok interessant also irgendwas
schon obenrum weniger wenig tun oder
wird dass gerade diese werden das
weniger
an alle chemiker unter euch erzählen
wenn irgendein chemie kam ein video
schaut warum wird das da gerade weniger
also ich meine es muss ja irgendwie
verdunsten das heißt da muss es ja
irgendwie über 100 grad in dem raum sein
oder wie löst sich das irgendwie auf mit
der zeit oder oder
oder also ich war ich war enorm
schlechte chemie
ich
nichtmal chemie weil ich physik und bio
gewählt habe fällt mir gerade aber das
verstehe ich ja wirklich gerade nicht
ich werde wahrscheinlich gerade komplett
gerostet in den kommentaren und jeder so
das kann nicht sein dass hat wie der
kinder hat gar das schon gelernt warum
hat irgendwie der fall ist aber das ist
ja es ist wirklich es ist warum lebten
das video jetzt die ganze zeit groß
stück fleisch für euch und zwar sieht
das ganze so aus es geht wieder in
stunden hoch und nicht in tagen wie bei
der milch oder dem wasser beispielsweise
und wir sehen bei dem fleisch schon ganz
klar also die ersten riesigen
veränderungen sieht man schon unter 24
stunden also das fleisch an der
einschätzung dass ich jetzt schon nicht
mehr essen allgemein würde ich auch nie
sonnen fette stück so krankes fleisch
essen so ich habe überlegt ob ich mal
überlege ob ich das wie und wie oft hast
will ich mich im heutigen bio ich habe
auf jeden fall überlegt 2020 gewisse
teile mal eine vegetarisch zu leben
vegan könnte ich nicht weil ich einfach
nicht so die disziplin habe das dann so
krass durchzuziehen und ich auch viel zu
gern essen gehe und neue sachen
ausprobieren aber vegetarisch halt
wirklich einfach nicht weil ich nicht
mag fleisch allgemein sondern weil ich
es halt weil es halt wirklich einfach
ungesund ist und deswegen hatte ich mir
überlegt vegetarisch zu leben aber das
sieht ja also wenn man das so sieht
alter der wähler welcher direkt
vegetarisch in einer gewissen form
könnte man jetzt noch denken dass es
vielleicht irgendeine art von panade ist
oder so es gibt ja auch oft irgendwie
hähnchenbrustfilet etwas sand
kräuterbutter oder so
oder ihnen
allein wie das hier so ist hier so hoch
und runter
das findet auch krass oder das fli
gesichtern denken oh ja vorher an den
fand ich nicht interessant aber jetzt wo
es so krass verschimmelt ist ein könig
midas und jetzt sieht man mal wie viele
da jetzt kommt das werden wir also das
geht ja gar nicht klar nach neun tagen
nur zum vergleich der bürger von
mcdonald's nach 80 tage hat man dann
nichts gewesen extrem heftig wird es
jetzt wahrscheinlich hierbei der tomate
sein
wir sind jetzt bei vier tagen schon
angelangt und ich würde so eine tomate
halt eher allgemein im kühlschrank
lagern damit sie halt länger haltbar ist
aber hier zieht dann schon nach ein abo
okay okay okay so krass hätte ich mir
ist jetzt nicht vorgestellt es ist sehr
fein muss man halt auch mal sagen wie
sich der schimmel dadurch frist dass sie
ziemlich geil aussieht so moos bedeckt
es keine ahnung was es an popular sie
wissen aus wie antipasti gibt sie auch
auf eben diese tomaten oder so peperoni
paprikas oder irgendwie sowohl an da
drin liegen wieso käse isst oder
irgendwie sowas da sie genauso aus wenn
das in dem antipasti restaurant liegen
würde
ja ok mit dem pelz oder wird man schon
so erkennen dass es so nicht so nicht so
frisch ist aber ich würde nehmen und mit
der keine gedanken drüber waren
allerdings sieht man ja jetzt eigentlich
schon das ergebnis was man sich erhofft
hat mehr oder weniger bzw was man
erwartet hat das heißt wir haben das
video ist noch so lang
ach es geht wieder zurück
wow
klar so frisch saß früher aus und
zwischen mein gott alter falls
irgendjemand sich dieses video hier
gerade anschaut und noch dabei am essen
ist alter ich gebe euch 70 milliarden
trillion alpakas trommel nun allerdings
schon zum letzten video das ich mir für
heute anschauen werde und zwar ist es
mobbing celli also schlecht werden der
wackelpudding
wie auch immer man dann auf die idee
kommt in so einem produktionsbüro keine
ahnung was das man sich denkt ja heute
lassen wir mal wackelpudding ein paar
tage vor der kamera stehen und lassen
ihn schlecht werden aber bisher also
wirklich sieht man ja schon wir sind
jetzt bei drei tagen und jetzt auch
schon bei vier tagen angekommen
es ist er sieht noch genauso wie vorher
ist natürlich auch eine menge gelatine
darin eine menge wasser und da sieht man
doch jetzt gehts aber jetzt geht's aber
los hier heidewitzka heilige mutter
gottes ok ja fängt an auszufließen und
hier um ein ok wo das ging jetzt das
gegen fix spürt man noch ein bisschen
vor
ach
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie so eine
kleine moos landschaft die man irgendwie
sind unter die den weihnachtsbaum an die
krippe stellt oder so stelle ich das
heute wieder ist allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare was ihr am krassesten
fandet also wenn mir war es auf jeden
fall der bürger vergleich wenn euch das
video gefallen hat das gern ein daumen
hoch unter dem video abonniert main
kanal falls doch genug zeit und jetzt
dass ich euch auch in ruhe und werde
wahrscheinlich eine woche lang nichts
mehr richtig essen können
[Musik]